or sticking with the theme of Music Il
Divo is taking the stage at The Encore
Theater at the win this weekend I talked
with one of the band members Sebastian
is embarred ahead of the show the band
has been through a lot this past year
but they are ready to tour and entertain
their fans take a look
[Music]
discovered in 2003 by Simon Cowell pop
Opera group Il Divo has become an
international sensation you know it
happened all of a sudden
and we were all very scared of how you
know there's so many phenomenons out
there like things are popping up and
you're big Monday and the next day
you're gone so we all had this fear you
know that it was just going to be a
momentum that momentum continued with
over 30 million records sold
[Music]
biggest venues in the world
foreign but earlier this year tragedy
struck the group when they lost one of
their band members to covid I want to
start out by telling you how sorry I am
for the loss of your band member Carlos
I'm guessing that this tour is kind of a
dedication to him
yes that's correct we are paying a
tribute to thank you for for uh being
sorry for that because it's it's been
really difficult we're very excited to
uh come back to Las Vegas and play the
win because
we're going to be celebrating Carlos's
life art
um the last 18 years that we spent
together you know it's he was um
like a brother to us and um I said that
many times during interviews you know if
Carlos would have been here one of us
would have left this world he would want
us you know they wouldn't want to
continue Legacy of Il Divo
[Music]
making this their mission El Divo is
taking their tour across the country and
have welcomed in a special guest to
share the stage and honor Carlos we have
a special guest called uh Stephen LaBrie
who we brought uh in our band because El
Divo is really the four voices and we're
not bariton the three of us
so we brought a baritone into uh the
band
and Stephen is delightful you know to
work with and he's also so um he was
such a fan of Carlos
um it's really beautiful to pay that
tribute to
um a friend who's left us their show at
the win will showcase every element of
the group from honoring their beloved
band member to getting you up and
dancing on your feet so we got a lot of
um different moments throughout the show
which I think is just really important
we can be just very
deep and and sad there's a lot of
emotions I find and Vegas has always and
will always hold a special place in the
hearts of Il Divo a few years back we
had a residency and uh
you know it it's
it's
been
one of my favorite highlights actually
of Il Divo so through the last 19 years
really
um
it's a very special place
you can experience the Il Divo greatest
hits tour at encore theater this Sunday
September 11th you can